hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game uh from the world
championship for girls under 20 or girls
world junior Championship where we have
a a very interesting match up between
meiu and karisa Yip now we've seen a
couple of games on this channel already
by both of them uh there is a bit of a
bit of an age difference me yulu is only
13 years old and here she's playing
against much much older players than
herself as karisa Yip is 20-year-old and
she is the highest rated player in the
tournament she's also in 2019 she won
the women's us Championship so uh she's
an incredible player and you can see by
her rating that he's she's much much
higher rated but you've also seen how
meu plays and that only means that she
uh will uh soon soon get the rating that
she deserves so let's check out this
game uh they faced each other in round
nine there are 11 rounds in this
tournament so after this round there are
two more round so let's check it out uh
we have Pawn to E4 and pawn to E5 Knight
F3 we have Knight to C6 and meu goes for
Bishop to B5 she goes for the ru Lopez
A6 morphy's defense by Karissa and
Bishop to A4 we have Knight to F6
castles and pawn to D6 now so uh the uh
the so-call the first sh is defense um
all pretty standard stuff here C3 Bishop
to D7 and now Rook to E1 and here okay
Bishop to D7 and Bishop to E7 are
standard moves in this line but we have
Pawn to G6 here also played quite a lot
so not a big deal here D4 Bishop to G7
and pawn to H3 now we have castles uh
and the bishop back to C2 adding more uh
defense to the4 pawn uh and here usually
you will see Rook to E8 or Knights to H5
or you will see Pawn to H6 here but
Karissa goes Queen to E8 she has a a
different idea and it's a very very
aggressive move so the queen will remain
on the eile The Rook will will control
the f file so we will move the Knight
and um execute this Pawn breakthrough
with Pawn to F5 and this Rook is coming
to d8 so that is her plan and it's a
very very tricky one to handle and of
course it is now as of move 10 that we
have a completely new game okay uh Mei
uh continues developing Knight B to D2
We have Knight to H5 and now Knight to
F1 preparing to counter this Knight with
Knight to G3 Pawn to F5 as intended and
E captures on F5 we have G captures in
the spirit of the position now you have
very strong Center here D captures on E5
D captures and Knight to G3 challenging
the Knight on H5 And karisa Trades we
have Knight captures F captures and
Bishop to E6 now preparing to get the
Rook into the game with Tempo uh so
Bishop to F4 this is where the fun
really Starts Now the the the absolute
best way to play this is Pawn to G4 you
you want to open up this diagonal and
now if F captures on G4 which is not the
way to go I'm just is going to show you
what happens then you go Knight to G5
and already black is facing some issues
here for example Bishop to F5 you will
trade here captures captures kick away
The Rook from the fifth Rank and after
The Rook moves Queen C2 and you have
constant pressure here uh against the
black king so uh G4 is best but this is
uh probably the most tricky Bishop to F4
now what's the idea behind Bishop to F4
can't the bishop just be captured
where's the trick well the trick is if
you capture the bishop Rook captures on
E6 is the trick and now if Queen
captures Bishop to B3 just cures the
queen and of course you lose the game so
after Bishop to F4 Rook to d8 of course
it's a free development move so let's
play it attacks the queen queen to B1
now still putting pressure on this
diagonal and now uh Bishop to C8 you
could also play Pawn to E4 Pawn to E4 is
very nice she decides to go for Bishop
to C8 and now Bishop to G5 putting
pressure on the rook and The Rook to D6
we have Pawn to G4 now uh and here we
have Pawn to H6 here F captures on G4 is
actually incredibly strong because if
you capture on H7 doesn't really do all
that much King to h8 H captur on G4 and
after Bishop captur on G4 you are very
happy here with black with your Rooks on
D and F5 the bishop here on G4 the queen
coming to H5 this is a a tremendous
position for black uh but she managed to
tricker Pawn to H6 was played weakening
Black's King side and now Bishop back to
E3 preparing to secure the Rook with
Bishop to C5 and she goes for Bishop cap
Pawn captures on G4 H captures Bishop
captures and now Knight to H2 we have
Queen to H5 sacrificing The Exchange
here uh and okay now he decides that
it's okay to go for it and she goes
Bishop to C5 so what's the idea behind
the exchange sacrifice uh Rook to D2 now
look at all this pressure against the
white king but Mei says nope it's not a
problem and she goes for material now
there are two ways you could handle this
one is to continue the game with black
and uh try to win it and the other one
is to force a draw on demand now the way
to force a draw is to actually play Rook
Capt on G2 now if um if Karissa wanted
to do this she could just play Rook
capis on G2 and it's a draw Queen H3
check now you can't go to H1 because of
Bishop to F3 you're going to have to
play King to G1 and now you force the
king to H1 King to H1 and now Bishop to
F3 check captures captures and if King
goes here you go here if King goes here
you go here and you have a
Perpetual
no no way for white to to continue
playing this so a draw if there if
Karissa wants it but she doesn't she
plays Bishop captures on f8 now with
some very nice ideas of Bishop coming to
C5 and you still have a lot of pressure
against um that white king So Okay
Bishop to B3 with check first king to h8
and now comes Queen to E4 and meu finds
a very nice centralizing move that stops
any Rook caps and G2 ideas and she now
says all right I'm up the exchange uh
you know if if you have a mate then
Checkmate me if not I'm going to enjoy
my my material so okay uh the the best
most precise way to play this is Bishop
to C5 check not because you have any uh
you know crazy attacking moves following
but simply because you take away the E3
Square from the White Queen but uh then
you can maybe play Bishop to F5 attack
the queen queen moves and so on uh but
after Bishop to F5 immediately now the
the E3 square is available for the White
Queen attacks The Rook now Rook captures
on B2 and now me you just plays Rook to
F1 now she's preparing Rook to F2 uh to
sort of double up but really to get rid
of this very strong attacker on B2 we
have Queen to G6 now threatening
Checkmate and now before going for Rook
to F2 uh Bishop to D5 first defending on
G2 and here karisa is actually still
better and she has a great position but
she has to find Pawn to B6 and it's
really not everyday move you find uh
because um it's not like a weird move on
the queen side or anything your your C6
Knight is defended and also you're
threatening Bishop to C5 B6 covers the
C5 Square so Bishop to C5 now becomes a
threat and even if you play Rook
captures on F5 which looks great Queen
captures on F5 and Rook to F1 now if the
queen moves Rook will capture on f8
there's
theug Rook to B1 and now there is no uh
good way to get out of this you have to
play Bishop to E4 and thenook captures
on F1 Knight captures on F1 you simply
move the Queen the Knight is defended
and the black enjoys a superior game
however uh she didn't play Pawn to B6
she played Pawn to E4 and here she sort
of blunders the uh the position uh so uh
try to figure out how she did it while I
give you a couple of seconds there is
only one good move for her
here
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
tricky move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
captures on e4 and it is exactly because
she missed this move uh she decided to
play this if she thought about the
position a little bit longer she would
have found B6 I'm sorry I don't have the
clock times for this tournament as uh
they're not provided on any website that
I'm I'm following so I don't know the
exact times see if any of you know what
the the time was for example for this
game where when E4 was played that would
be very much appreciated but okay Bishop
captures on e4 was played and now the
problem is if you play Bishop captures
on e4 now uh Rook captures on f8 the
bishop just hangs and after King to H7
yes check mid is being threatened on all
sides here
but you have the saving Rook F2 that's
the point and now once you trade you
don't really have anything with black
that's just it white will have a maybe
not winning but close to winning like
okay you can play Knight D5 you still
have to deal with a couple of um
attackers in front of your king but
after Rook to F1 no no worries here the
Knight can't really move otherwise you
just trade queens and uh you you should
be able to win this so after Bishop
captures on e4 Knight to E7 was played
and now Queen to D4 with check now the
last chance for karisa is to play King
to H7 but it's not a not really a great
chance because you will you will play
Rook captures on F5 remember the bishop
still covers Checkmate so that that
truly is a hero there after the bishop
captured that pawn on e4 and after
Knight captures there's Queen to D7
check again connecting with the Knight
here so King h8 You'll Play Queen
captures on F5 and okay you will win a
pawn with Rook captures is now okay the
bishop cannot take because of Queen
captures on F5 but after King H1 there
is Queen captures on F5 Bishop captures
you're just going to move the rook and
um okay white white should be winning
this as uh you know you're up up a full
piece so after Queen to D4 check Bishop
to G7 is the only practical attempt uh
and now comes Queen to d8 with check uh
King to H7 uh and now Rook captures on
F5 of course uh so how do you defend
Knight captures and F5 but now Rook to
F1 nicely piling up on the Knight here
and look at this bishop still guarding
against Checkmate I mean what a hero
this bishop on e4 uh Rook to B5 yes you
defend but Queen to D7 just introduces a
third attacker on F5 so no point in
doing that rook captur and G2 is the
only other attempt that was left for
Karissa bishop captur and G2 and now
Knight to E3 threatening Checkmate uh
but now Rook to F2 defending the bishop
uh we have Queen to B1 with check and
now Bishop to F1 this bishop just doing
all all all the work for all the pieces
this game Queen to G6 with check Bishop
to G G2 and now Queen back to B1 check
now Knight to F1 of course you have to
play it otherwise it's going to be a
repetition Knights to G4 attacking The
Rook but just Rook to F4 we have Queen
to B6 with check okay you do have some
pressure with the queen and Knight but
after King to H1 that's pretty much it
Knight to F6 was played uh the point is
if Knight to F2 check uh you can just
play Rook captures on F2 there's no way
black and play this you're just up too
much material and also you are getting
checkmated uh Bishop D4 check and that's
it also one thing to remember in your
own games when when you have a um a game
with Bishops of opposite color and not
like an end game there are still Queens
on the board and everyone's attacking
when you're attacking with a light
Square bishop and a queen and your
opponent is trying to defend with a dark
Square Bishop it's like your opponent is
actually down a piece uh as there's no
way for the dark Square Bishop to oppose
the light Square Bishop a useful thing
to remember and that's it pretty much
after Queen F5 this will be Checkmate so
after Knight H1 uh King to H1 the move
you had to find after Knight to F6 is a
very tricky one uh but um well there are
many winning moves here me played one of
them but there's actually a forced
Checkmate in 12 which I'm pretty sure
you guys can see even by just you know
looking at the position and uh if it was
the only winning move of course meu
would have found it but there are many
winning moves so she decided to go for
one that does not um uh you know uh take
a lot of calculating something cou
Blanca for example was very fond of if
you had like a game you could win with
brilliant sacrifices and you could Al
also win it with a pawn push capablanca
would just push a pawn and that's it uh
so uh she played Bishop to H3 but the
move that I'm sure you guys found as you
are comfortable in your own home or
maybe driving a car uh is Rook captures
on F6 and it doesn't matter if Queen
captures then King has no squares after
Bishop to E4 check so you have to play
Bishop captures and I'll look at this
queen D7 check Bishop to G7 now Bishop
to E4 check and after King to G8 you
just force the king back we have Bishop
to f8 now Bishop to D5 check King to H7
Queen to F7 check Bishop to G7 and now
you finally get your position Bishop to
E4 with check again the star piece of
this game the light Square Bishop King
h8 and now Queen T8 check no more
squares for the black king bishop f8 and
queen captors will be Checkmate so this
is one way to do it she decided to go
the other way Bishop to H3 now she wants
to hit it with Bishop to F5 with check
so Queen to C6 check allowing this one
check King to H2 and now Pawn to H5
freeing up the H six square for the
black king as well but now Bishop F5
check King to H6 and now Queen to D2 and
it was in this position on move 46 that
karisa Yip resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so
brilliant brilliant game by 13-year-old
meu and you resign here as okay the King
has nowhere to go you are under the mask
of the rook and you will suffer some
terrible discoveries here one thing you
one maybe move you could do to counter
it is Queen to D6 this uh prevents The
Rook from moving as you are also pinning
it with the queen uh but white of course
welcomes a queen trade because white is
just up too much material for example C
captures now you play really anything
you're up a full rook and of course
completely winning uh so yeah uh that's
the game I hope you guys enjoyed it like
I said this was not the penultimate
round this was the ninth round of the 11
rounds that will be played in this
tournament uh in round 10
karisa was the leader going into round
nine but now with this loss to meu meu
corupt her both of them now on seven
points but the leader of the tournament
is Bulgarian International master belava
crasta who is on seven and a half points
and she will be me L's uh next opponent
in round 10 we'll see what she does
against her and uh you know can she take
it all the way she's much much younger
than all of them like karisa is 20 I
think Bellos laava is like 18 or 19 uh
uh so you know
she's uh much younger but she's holding
her own I mean playing incredible chess
here uh who knows how strong she will be
next year uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
wish a very happy birthday to aam and I
would also like to thank George de
Gregorio Jonathan Johnson Robert taton
and Sashi darita puru for contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and thank you for all the
wonderful comments on the games that I'm
playing that I'm I've been uploading for
the past few days if you have a like a
specific opening that you would like me
to use I you know I don't mind learning
it uh you know to try it out in in a
rapid game uh thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day